>>> Tonight lethal support as
U.S. Officials warn beijing may
soon supply weapons to Russia to
use in Ukraine, but already
there are signs that China is
providing crucial help to prop
up Putin's forces.
Will Ripley has more in this
"Outfront" investigation.
[ Sirens ]
>> Reporter: What will it take
to stop the suffering, the
senseless slaughter of Russia's
unprovoked war on Ukraine?
One year in, president Vladimir
Putin has a problem, ammo is
running low.
The U.S. Government says Russia
will run out of serviceable
ammunition this year.
Moscow denies they have a fading
arsenal, forcing their military
to conserve unless they get
help.
Help the U.S. And nato say could
come from China.
>> To date we have seen Chinese
companies and, of course, in
China there's no distinction
between private companies and
the state, we have seen them
provide nonlethal support to
Russia for use in Ukraine.
The concern that we have now is
based on information we have
that they're considering
providing lethal support.
>> Reporter: China denies it
calling the claims unfounded, a
ploy, a smear.
Beijing and Moscow declared a no
limits partnership last year.
CNN obtained a new report
showing Moscow may already be
getting a boost on the
battlefield from beijing.
Troves of trade data, collected
and supplied by the center for
advanced studies, a D.C. Think
tank that shows China sending
Russian defense companies
sophisticated parts.
>> We see the nature of these
parts being labeled for use in
military systems.
>> Reporter: CNN did not verify
the data showing a steady supply
of parts, dramatically
increasing after the invasion.
They could be helping Russia
resupply.
Roors for attack helicopter,
radar antenna parts for
anti-aircraft missile systems
sent to a Russian defense
company labeled for military
use, the think tank says.
Their data shows military
assistance from several Chinese
companies, even before the war,
dual use aircraft, radar and lab
equipment.
Flowing into Russia 268 times.
Shipped by polygroup or
polytechnologies, a state-backed
Chinese arms manufacturer.
CNN contacted polygroup for
comment along with several other
Chinese companies shown in the
data.
So far no response.
>> Any trade between a
sanctioned Chinese state owned
defense company and a Russian
sanctioned defense company
during wartime, any trade really
at all is indicative of a
growing partnership that
potentially be of concern.
>> Reporter: The data implies
deepening cooperation, the U.S.
Suspects China of creeping
closer and closer to fully
supporting Russia's war.
The consequences for Ukraine
could be catastrophic.
>> Sudden inflow of Chinese
weapons into the Russians could
fundamentally shift the dynamics
in Moscow's favor.
>> Reporter: When asked about
allegations of backing Moscow,
beijing blames Washington.
[ Speaking non-english ]
Saying, it's the U.S., not China
providing a steady stream of
weapons on the battlefield.
Off the battlefield, trade data
reveals Russia may be bypassing
western sanctions buying
blacklisted advanced technology
from beijing.
The kind of tech Putin's army
needs to power high-tech weapons
and communication systems.
Why would China risk so much for
Russia?
>> It's in their interest to
have a Russian victory and to
have the United States and its
lies humiliated.
>> Reporter: Meeting in Moscow
Wednesday just two days after
president Biden's surprise trip
to Kyiv, democracy and
autocracy, a fight for the
future of Ukraine and perhaps
the free world.
The Chinese foreign minister
made that high-profile visit to
Moscow just before the one-year
anniversary of Russia's invasion
of Ukraine and that meeting is
widely believed to be a
precursor for a meeting in the
coming months between Chinese
president XI jinping and Russian
president Vladimir Putin.
What exactly they'll discuss
remains an open question whether
it's China's widely publicized
peace plan or something else.
But what is clear is that this
cooperation, this tie between
Russia and China remains rock
solid.
The world's two largest
authoritarian powers both
nuclear armed.
Kate.
>> Will, thank you so much.
>>> And CNN has reached out to
Russia for comment on this
report but hasn't gotten a
response.
Kremlin spokesman dmitry peskov
pushed back on ammunition
shortages telling "The wall
Street journal," Russia has